good morning reg good morning Theodor
seems like everyone's getting a video
tribute nowadays yeah you got one when
you retired
would you if you went back to the
mothership would they give you a video
tribute as they should but would they
you should get one but would they give
you one they wouldn't but maybe
individual like Scott Van Pelt did when
I went back there yeah it had some
couple of nice pictures there but you
know I don't think the network would I I
don't need a video tribute if I go back
to the mothership or if I did oh you
don't need it because they actually have
your statue as a campus no you don't
need a video interview because they see
your statue every single day absolutely
absolutely
yes yes in fact Jordan and the Bulls got
the idea from my statue with the
mothership and that's what they did when
they based that they put that outside
Chicago Stadium make sense all right
help me with the Cavaliers with what's
going on that according to Adrienne
loads and around ski in a locker room
increasingly full of finger-pointing
Kevin Love defended himself and
explained his side to teammates coaches
and management at the end of the meeting
there was a sense of with some of the
team that they had worked out some of
the issues but ultimately remains to be
seen they were not happy that Kevin Love
may not have been fully sick when he
left the game early left the building
early on Saturday help me with what's
going on here in Cleveland Reggie
well number one you could have way too
many player only or team meetings
there's times for them obviously the
Cavs have really struggled since
Christmas I'm not quite sure this is one
of those times for those meetings
because I hearken back and I know people
don't like to talk about Jordan or magic
or Larry Bird but you are playing with
arguably the greatest player in his
generation and LeBron James and if you
can't bring the maximum effort whether
you're hurt or sick on a nightly basis
then individually something's wrong with
you again we you and I on the outside
looking in so we don't
what they're assuming or alleging Kevin
Love did again we're on the outside
looking in but I did the game Toronto
versus Cleveland when Cleveland was
going through the middle of that spell
when they lost badly at Minnesota they
lost badly at Toronto the effort that
Kevin Love was displaying was horrible
and I think that's the frustration level
that his teammates are facing with him
and if you can bring that you we all
remember Michael Jordan getting into
fight with Steve Kerr that competitive
drive same name with magic same thing
with Larry you wanted to almost die
playing with these guys and if you can
give that maximum effort something is
wrong with you you don't need a players
only meeting for that do you think Kevin
Love wants out
I really believe that rolls and this is
so late in the game and after a
championship so many late years later
coach Lou has to do a better job of
defining roles I thought Kevin loved to
start the season with Isaiah Thomas hurt
with the clear-cut pecking order and
played well number two on that team for
whatever reason things have gone gray
there's a gray area there and I just
don't think roles are that defined for
Kevin Love does he want out possibly but
where where are you going to go and
compete at a high level not playing with
the greatest player of your generation
and LeBron James it how can you not
bring that maximum effort but he won his
title and maybe he's just tired of this
drama there's there's always drama there
and maybe he can go to you know a
situation like he had in Minnesota where
he can play his 35 minutes and get his
24 and 14 and live happily ever after
there and what sadly about that there's
a lot of players like that yeah I am NOT
for Kevin Love of that because I think
he was instrumental in them winning that
ring for Cleveland so I'm not going to
label him that way but there are players
like that they just want the stats after
they get the ring and their life is
complete but if
you want to stand for something more for
bigger big every night you lace them up
in Cleveland your play you should be
playing for a purpose because you're
playing with a great player that's how
it should always be Theodore
but why all this drama and it's all I
know that we focus on LeBron and the
Cavs but he he has to be a facilitator
with with a lot of this drama here
isn't this the roster that he wanted he
wanted Kevin Love he wanted Kyrie out he
got Korver in there
they kept Tristan Thompson and jr. Smith
he got tyronn lue in as his head coach
so what what am I missing here well I
would say this I don't think he wanted
Kyrie out I thought Kyrie was a huge
part of this team because he had evolved
into the go-to guy so I'm not quite sure
LeBron wanted him out but yeah just make
up this team obviously has the
fingerprints and he got the coach too
yeah let's not forget about Blatt and
Alou the whole thing there too so he got
the coach you wanted so yeah the Cavs
fingerprints obviously have LeBron James
all over them and on top of that at the
end of the day he won't commit you know
he's got to do next summer so that's
what makes it even more challenging if
your calves and management because you
don't have that that committal from your
best player but but what do you do reg
we're approaching the trade deadline
what February 8th are they more likely
or less likely to do something big in
Cleveland to me I think well big would
be obviously trying to bring in someone
like a DeAndre Jordan maybe for Tristan
Thompson and I'm not quite sure they
want to come off that number one pick
that they have because there's a lot of
great college players that could
potentially not be the next LeBron but
can fill a void if he was to go
somewhere else so I'm not quite sure
they want to come off that number one
pick again it makes it challenging
because he's been non-committal but
having said all that the Cavs are in the
East and there's only two or three teams
that they really have to worry about if
at all and that's Boston in Toronto
and you've got to beat that dude four
times and I know things are kind of
bleak right now in Cleveland but with no
back to back you've got to beat in the
bronze Eames four times and I know
they're having a lot of issues up the
defensive end Jerry Smith it's been
awful but you still got to beat them
four times did I just you're putting a
lot of onus on Toronto and Boston as
well as they've been playing the two
best teams in the East I I'm still
rolling with the Cavs there's still a
lot of times for them to turn this
around Dan we're talking to Reggie
Miller NBA on TNT reg has the Wizards at
the Thunder at 8:00 Eastern on TNT this
week the Bucs future is that a good job
or a great job Oh a great job great
young talent obviously in object to [ __ ]
PO you have Middleton you know one thing
that people are not talking about I know
Jason Kidd was let go but he didn't have
Jabari Parker really almost for two
years because of the knee injuries he
was in and out but not at all this
season and they're still sitting seven
and a game and a half really out of the
fifth spot
it was interesting quotes coming out of
that conversation between the honest and
Jay kid when obviously Yanis found out
before Jay Kidd and the phone call and
you know do you want me to call man in
Japan you want me to call my agent
the interesting thing Jay kid says is
don't worry about it what it's done is
done but just tell the truth tell the
truth about what there's some
underlining factor that's going on
either between Jason Kidd and his
coaching staff and management or
ownership tell the truth about what
that's what I would want to know it was
weird the chain of command that it went
from management to star player to the
soon-to-be fired coach I thought that
that was pretty interesting that very
rare does that happen because number one
you never want to upset your you know
you're 21 22 year old you know future
icon player in on TD kupo but they felt
that they probably had to get ahead of
the story and Yanis was not happy about
it obvious
and coach Kidd very close they have that
Nike relationship so I think it was
unsettling for him but you've got to go
to him first and saying this is what
we're probably this is what we're
thinking of this is what we're probably
going to do and you're probably about to
get on board with them I know they just
signed the deal see this is why great
players in the small markets they start
looking elsewhere because the disability
is not there and for whatever reason
management felt that coach Kidd had
maxed his coaching ability capacity with
this young team and to me I think
there's another dynamic that people
aren't talking about the Eric Bledsoe
trade I don't know if Jason Kidd was on
board with it or not on board with it
because Malcolm Brogdon last year's
Rookie of the Year I thought was a great
piece for them and every you and I talk
about this all the time about chemistry
and how big that is especially for a
young team everyone had a role on this
team including Malcolm Brogdon
the Rookie of the Year last year so when
Bledsoe came in and I'm not putting this
on Bledsoe but it kind of changed a
little bit because the ball had to be in
Bledsoe's hand a little bit more as
opposed to on two takubo who was the
point forward Center on this team so it
changed a little bit and I'm not quite
sure of Jason Kidd was on board with it
or wasn't on board with it because it
changed the chemistry in the dynamic of
the Milwaukee Bucks before I let you go
I did want to ask you about this that
the captain's picks is not going to be
televised with LeBron and Steph Curry
and I know that maybe you don't want to
hurt somebody's feelings but my thought
is why couldn't you have LeBron and
Steph just do the starting five and you
don't have to do the full roster where
somebody is going to be the last guy
selected for the all-star team roster
just do a starting five with these two
guys I mean that would be fun if if
Steph takes or he's gonna go draft you
know throat Kyrie Irving just just
because you know or LeBron is gonna
draft Kyrie like there's a little bit of
drama in there or LeBron is gonna take
Kevin Durant like that's fun
I can't we do the starting five-year reg
and you know not worry about so many
feelings 100% agree with you and number
one I'm to the point who cares about
someone's feelings anyways you're still
going to be an all-star so who cares if
you're picked laughs the drama the whole
point of I am assuming why the league
wanted to do captain's and let's do it
playground style and we'll I'll pick my
team here pick your team that's the
drama about it that's how we all grew up
and who cares if you're the last player
pick you're still in the game so people
want to see is Steph gonna pick Russell
Westbrook or would LeBron took pick
Russell Westbrook are they gonna try to
keep Katie in Westbrook always I want to
see that so to me the league is they're
missing the point and they're dropping
the ball on this because I think it
would be magic for this to be on
television and the drama behind it
because that was the whole point I
thought was for these two guys the
captains deleting vote-getters to pick
their squads yes they're missing out on
an opportunity it's a tune in factor and
just to see the drama or who somebody
likes more than somebody else or who
they want to play it who cares about
feelings oh my goodness these are grown
men that are making multi-million dollar
are you kidding me you get your feelings
hurt because you're picked last in an
all-star game man suck it up would you
pick Jordan or bird with your first pick
if you were captain personally yeah he
plays the same position as I so if you
magic or Larry you're taking you're
taking magic I'm taking man yes magical
treat of all great reg we'll be in
Oklahoma City Wizards at the Thunder
8:00 Eastern on tea and
this week is that Thursday night that is
Thursday night all right
safe travels reg thanks for joining us
talk to you soon appreciate if these are
Janet love you that's Reggie Aloysius
Miller junior the third for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]